okay let's take our next caller our next
caller is coming in to us via Skype
caller of what's your name where are you
calling from and what's on your mind
today my name is Pascal ooh-whoo I'm
from Ottawa Canada and I'm calling in
regards to a recent altercation between
William and rebel media and Tommy
Robinson okay I have no idea what you're
talking about but what what is what
happened and what's your question so so
let me explain what happened what
happened was that Julia Abner a
journalist and a member of Quilliam
wrote an article on the far-right its
influences and Tommy Robinson happened
to be one of the topics so Tommy Robson
didn't like this because he felt he was
labeled as a white supremacist Julia
Abner states that that was not her
intention
so Tommy Robinson went to the offices of
Quilliam he trespassed and with the
camera into the offices and started
interrogating the individuals within
that that place and there's a rebel
media video that's associated to that my
question I guess would be uh in your
mind would this be something that she
would consider okay for any journalistic
organization to do basically break into
an office
oh so breaking into an office absolutely
not and I think the more interesting
question is my view on ambush journalism
because I don't think it will be
surprising to most of our audience to
hear that I'm not for LA breaking in
that way and criminality there's a
different question though which is more
about ambush journalism and this concept
of showing up unannounced and sticking a
microphone and/or camera in someone's
face I understand the instinct or desire
to want to do that when you feel as
though someone is is deliberately
avoiding answering questions about
something which may be relevant to
public interest but I'm generally
against that policy I think
it's problematic in a number of ways
journalistically and our view has always
been Pat we schedule an interview if if
there's an interview that we want and
someone is refusing or ignoring us we'll
state that but I have not been of the
mind of just showing up and doing the
ambush interview and you know what
people just some people disagree with me
on this and they say David no to really
get the truth that you sometimes have to
show up Michael Moore has done it and
you know I think there's a difference
when Michael Moore shows up on announced
like he did in one of his older
documentaries and I forget I think it's
Roger and me and he might have shown up
at GM or wherever he's showing up
unannounced and asking for an interview
that's different than waiting outside
someone's house to put a camera in their
face it's too bad though when legitimate
reporters are accused of ambush
journalism and perhaps even arrested for
trespassing or some other bogus charge
that happened to Amy Goodwin I think
from Democracy Now just a couple of
months ago for covering the Dakota
access pipeline yeah she was involved in
some charges Amy Goodman from Democracy
Now although I don't remember exactly
what the circumstances were but I do
remember completely manufactured and
made up it was okay yeah I didn't I
didn't know too much about the story so
anyway I think that that's the more
interesting question Pascale although
you know as far as the criminality I'm
against breaking into places I think I
not there grew with you on both points
because it really matters in regards to
how constructive the discussion can be
when you're basically in somebody's face
in that fashion yeah I agree with you
all right thank you very very much for
the call appreciated important topic
although I don't I have not familiarized
myself with the specifics of that story